fire
no single tool in the human arsenal
explains our existence organ fire from
an animal like any other to the dominant
species on earth because we figured out
how to feel from the heaven and harness
the power of the Sun it was a piece of
magic so exceptional so inexplicable we
told our children and with a distance of
God and turned it into a myth to be
handed down for thousands of years
heat nourishment transportation
communication annihilation
fire made us warriors and builders and
explorers with each advance we paid with
our blood
but still we kept going and today and we
break through the bonds of birth and
escape our cage the only thing we see
when we look back is the life of our
greatest compliment like a flame that
cannot be extinguished the drive within
us to create expand and dominate not
just this world but the next the very
spark of humanity starts here with fire
this is origin
[Music]
you